[Musique]
le caviar est séparé en deux catégories
il y a vraiment le caviar d'esturgeon
qui est la crème de la crème et ensuite
il y a tout ce qu'on appelle la gamme
d'oeuf de poisson c'est des bons
alternatifs aux caviars d'esturgeon
justement dû au budget mais il faut
s'attendre au niveau goût on parle de
quelque chose complètement différent moi
si
est-ce que je vais
voir ça il y a une goutte très grosse
différence si on parle justement en
allant du caverne d'esturgeon jusqu'au
Massago ou à l'inverse du Massago
jusqu'au caviar d'esturgeon je veux
goûter
les œufs de capelan ou si nommés Massago
sont les plus petits et les plus
abordables
ça se goût qu'on connaît sur des sushis
par exemple qu'on retrouve assez
régulièrement là
exactement donc le Massago c'est
carrément une préparation asiatique où
on va retrouver du soya du sucre du sel
et toute une variété d'ingrédients et
c'est vraiment pour décorer plus
qu'autre chose de la taille d'une tête
d'épingle les œufs de lampe
naturellement pâles sont semi-rées et
colorés d'un noir ou d'un rouge brillant
oh ça c'est salé oui donc la
particularité des œufs de l'homme c'est
vraiment sa teneur en sel on parle de 8
à 10% de sel
les œufs de truite et de saumon tiennent
leurs belles teint orangée des crustacés
dont ils se nourrissent ils sont
beaucoup utilisés dans les bols et les
plats asiatiques au niveau goût c'est la
même chose la grosse différence c'est
vraiment la taille et ça ce que ça va
faire les œufs de saumon ça va être plus
doux et ça va éclater plus facilement en
bouche
œuf de poisson le plus recherché au
monde est évidemment celui de
l'esturgeon ces minuscules baignoires
sont un produit de grand luxe pour
lequel il est possible de débourser une
petite fortune soit autour de 250
dollars le petit pot les autres œufs
coûte entre 4 et 12 dollars je
commencerai avec le caviaire de
l'aquaculture et je pense que c'est pas
que j'avais des goûts de luxe
mais c'est crémeuse
au niveau goût vous voyez que c'est
vraiment drastique comme différence
le caviar d'esturgeon dans le passé
provenir principalement de la pêche
entre autres de la mer Caspienne mais de
nos jours le caviar d'esturgeon vient
uniquement de la culture à l'exception
de deux places dans le monde le Québec
et le Nouveau-Brunswick ou la pêche
sauvage d'esturgeons et encore permise
mais pourquoi nous on le permet donc les
raisons est simple c'est que au niveau
de l'environnement naturel il est assez
désurgeons autant dans le lac
Saint-Pierre que dans les estuaires du
fleuve Saint-Laurent
[Musique]
avant que vous goûtez le caviar des
selon du Québec la grosse différence est
c'est que c'est un produit sauvage il y
a pas de procédé de nettoyage comme
l'agriculture comme vous pouvez voir que
c'est vraiment une couleur verte qui est
vraiment les algues qu'on retrouve au
fond du Saint-Laurent ou encore du lac
Saint-Pierre
la teneur en sel de sel qui a la
première attaque c'est aussi soyeux mais
beaucoup plus prononcé c'est vraiment ça
la grosse différence entre un caviar
d'élevage et un caviar sauvage
les œufs de poissons se mangent surtout
en accompagnement mais on les trouve
aussi à la base de certains mais le chef
constant Manza nous propose un plat
typiquement grec la taramo salata
pour lier l'huile les multiplier dans ce
que c'est mais la protéine vient des
œufs de poissons
[Musique]
et on rajoute du citron pour acidifier
avec avec du pain centre de table
penser la grosse tablée avec plein de
petits trucs mais c'est un peu
équivalent d'une betterave marinière
ça fait partie de la table est
traditionnelle grecque sur la c'est
comme parfait on dirait même que c'est
comme un fromage à la crème ou
c'est soyeux c'est vraiment très bon
on trouve aussi sur le marché un
condiment typiquement italien fait deux
de mulet salé et sécher en bloc la
Bottarga c'est la Bottarga qu'on met
dans la poêle qu'on mélange donc là je
fais légèrement toaster le poivre ça
fait partie de la cuisine populaire la
cuisine pauvre sicilienne
j'ai rajouté la boîte à rigueur
j'aimerais juste rajouter un peu plus de
bottargir ça et un peu de chapelure ça
remplacerait le fromage dans le fond
avec une pâte au poisson c'est pas un
plat très protéiné mais j'imagine très
goûteux quand oui parce que la botarie
quelque chose aussi de très tranchant
comme vous soit on aime soit on n'aime
pas donc on y goûte puis on le sait tout
de suite parce que ça goûte la mer c'est
un petit côté légèrement d'amertume mais
très poisson aussi on peut le retrouver
à l'apéro soit seulement trancher là qui
peut se manger comme ça ou bien ici
ricotta ou un fromage vraiment qui dans
le fond a pas été assigné mais juste
comme ça moi je trouve ça impeccable ça
donne vraiment beaucoup de goût au parc
tout à fait
[Musique]